was this something you both wanted to do
to be in this business I had no
intention of doing this I was a really
shy kid growing and once I came to LA to
go to school I kind of got forced into
an acting class and I remember auditing
the class the first day and the first
people on stage they're screaming and
crying and hitting each other and I was
like no no no no this is not for me but
like I stuck it out because I've just
always loved movies and I guess I felt
that this was maybe a path into it when
you saw James do it did you think I want
to do it too or no no not at all and I
just never I'd never performed in any
way I was so nervous but you were you
worked in an old school videotape movie
rental shop growing up right right yeah
like that means that's a guy who loves
movies yes teenager yes I was 14 years
old and my first job I was working at a
mom and pop video store and it was
actually illegal for me to be working
there at that age so they they basically
paid me by allowing me to take home as
many movies as I wanted and so that was
like my film School